he said it he said it
welcome to the heavy spoiler show i'm
your host paul aka
the warrior that built this town in this
video we're breaking down
everything you need to know about sweet
home the korean netflix show
has a lot to unpack from it and
throughout this video we're going to be
discussing the main plot points of the
series
it's ending and where things could be
going for season 2. obviously there will
be heavy spoilers here so if you don't
anything ruined then i highly recommend
that you check out now
if you're giving in to your deepest
desires and staying then please smash
the thumbs up button
and make sure you subscribe to the
channel for videos like this every day
without the way thank you for clicking
this now let's get into the breakdown
okay so sweet home is loosely based on
the webtoon of the same name
and the series follows the inhabitants
of the green home apartment building
as they battle against some incredible
creatures intent on tearing them limb
from limb
predominantly we follow cha hyun-soo who
has just moved into the area
and sees he unites with the other
survivors to take down the monsters
hyun-soo suffers from depression and one
of the first times that we catch the
character
he's contemplating taking his own life
we discover that he was bullied in
school
and this made the troubled teen shut
himself off from the world
no matter what he did just caused more
anguish and after he attempted to stand
up to the bully
his father ended up losing his job this
was also the catalyst for the death of
his friend's mother
and thus he retreated inside himself
completely cutting himself off from most
social interactions
sadly his family died due to a car
accident and the grief and loneliness of
this have hurt him to the point that
he's vowed to end it all
however those plans quickly change when
korea is wracked with a seemingly
mysterious disease
that randomly turns people into monsters
now zombie properties are a
dime a dozen at this point and in
regards to korea we've had several of
them popping up over the last couple of
years including
train to busan kingdom and hashtag alive
where sweet home separates itself though
is that it operates with monsters rather
than zombies
and though many of the plot points are a
bit by the numbers it makes it stand out
from the crowd because of this aesthetic
as we journey through the work we
discover that it's not a virus causing
these mutations
but rather a curse that is based on an
individual's desires
thus the thing that ultimately drives a
person becomes their downfall
but beyond that it's not really
explained how why people fall victim to
it
however it does very much hammer home
the motif that this show will focus
highly on people
and what their hearts desire and though
the cgi can be a bit hit and miss
the core plot elements actually do a
really good job of fleshing out the key
characters
so that they're multi-layered normally
in zombie stories the archetypes feel
very one-dimensional
and whilst that could have been the case
here sweet home actually has
a lot of people in it with distinct
personalities absolutely
love this idea as not only was it
present in those that we encountered but
the monsters
also had individualistic designs meaning
that you could read into a lot of the
subtext
and see why certain things were the way
they were every monster that emerges is
as twisted as the person that became it
and it really leads to a lot of
interesting showdowns we learn that they
are at their most vulnerable during the
golden hours
and this means that they can be defeated
even if it's extremely difficult
now one of the main symptoms of the
curse is a nosebleed in which the
infected person
gushes blood all over their face i still
have no idea how they did this effect
and it's something that instantly alerts
the person on the receiving end of it
that something is wrong
hyun-soo actually comes down with the
curse very early on
but unlike the rest of those that we
encounter he doesn't actually transform
and instead he gains what could be seen
as immortality
now why this is important is because the
character actually had a strong desire
to end his own life
to the point that he even planned out
the day and date that it would happen
however the curse in some ways reverses
that and makes it so that the character
cannot die
which allows him to become an asset for
the rest of the survivors
these survivors as a whole all represent
different stages of life
and we have some that are in love others
that are old and some shady members
who well the less said about the better
i'm not gonna get into each and every
one of them as you'd be here all day but
the characters evolve
over time and a lot of them go on their
own arcs in which they become almost
polar opposites to how they were at the
start of the season we discovered that
they survived far
longer than a lot of the other peoples
in similar situations across the country
and this is because
they work as a team really well now as
with most supernatural apocalypse shows
we see that the real monsters the real
monsters mate
it's the bloody humans and the apartment
block is taken over by a bunch of
outlaws
that will kill you just for looking at
them the group are completely vile
nihilistic blood drinking sadists that
completely change the dynamics of the
latter part of the season
mirroring this we see that all the
monsters aren't bad and there's actually
one in the events that helps young sue
just a heads up yeah i'm probably gonna
butcher a lot of these names but i'm
trying my best to pronounce them
i did listen to the dub version and yeah
it's a bit difficult to make some of
them out anyway
the group managed to ambush the gang and
take some of them down but during this
yun-soo's secret is revealed and they
escort him in an elevator to the roof of
the building
however a big twist comes when one of
the forces a man named yumyong
reveals himself as a monster and he
switches sides after viewing the gang as
crossing the line
we discover he volunteered for several
experiments in order to have the curse
removed from him
but that it failed because the monster
isn't in him it is him
he sees himself almost as an apex
predator a wolf in sheep's clothing that
exists amongst the humans
and will strike if pushed into it he
promises not to harm the survivors
but doesn't believe that humans will
show him the same courtesy
and that one way or another they will
all be wiped out because of evolution
yum young thinks it's impossible for
normal people to coexist with the cursed
and that they will try and wipe them out
no matter what this is hammered home by
the survivors burning up the vent one
that saved young soo
and also special military leaflets that
are dropped on the property
these offer sanctuary to anyone willing
to hand over an infected person
and thus they will be safe from
operation golden hour
which involves wiping everything off the
map monsters and humans alike
it really leads to there being a big
predicament for the finale
and it becomes clear that hyun-soo and
yu-myeong are no longer welcome
after uri has an asthma attack sang-wook
tries to leave with her
but yum young intervenes and stops them
both
left with little option hyun soo
realizes that he's not good for the camp
and agrees to leave with him in order to
spare the others
sang-wook takes yurai outside but
yu-myeong goes fully off the deep end
and mercilessly shoots not only the pair
but also
indiscriminately at the other survivors
as we know
myeong is invincible and this pushes
hyunsu into embracing his monster side
which leads to him growing a gigantic
wingarm laced with spikes
traditionally in anime half men half
bird creatures
represents someone who is walking the
line between humanity and being a beast
i love this scene and seeing him take
down the villain to a final
fantasy-esque heart pumping moment
i thought was absolutely amazing do sick
arrives and embraces him which allows
the character to return back to normal
but he's completely broken by what he's
been through i think the line it's not
your fault has a lot of significance
here
as hyun soo blames himself not only for
his family's death
but also the ones that yumiyun caused by
possessing other characters and so on
however this it's not your fault line
reminds us that all the things that he
blames himself for
aren't his fault and well it's quite a
touching moment
now outside sang wuk and yurai pass away
holding each other's hands
which too feels like one of the perfect
ways for them to close out their arc
it is an overall for one of the
characters but we'll discuss this more
in a bit
and hyun-soo wakes up looking more like
how he did in the flash forward that
kickstarted episode 1.
the character has complete amnesia and
can't remember do sick
or the events that transpired we joined
mr ran
who throughout the latter part of the
series was digging a tunnel
and unfortunately the character passes
away in his sleep
however the group uncovered the door
that he was trying to locate
and this provides them with an escape in
the end unfortunately
things aren't over though and yumyong
slides out of the corpse
that he had possessed and he takes the
outlaws truck and escapes
the military arrives and demand that the
infected are handed over
and though they don't initially fire
they're soon given cause to
after the last outlaw sets off a booby
trap in the tunnels the survivors flee
there
and hyun-soo decides to face the
military head-on
which brings everything full circle from
the scene in the opening
hyun-soo heads into a barrage of bullets
as the rest of the group make their way
into the tunnels in order to escape
though they initially become lost after
little rescue dog bomb arrives
he leads them to the outside which
allows them to finally leave the area
now they are surrounded by soldiers and
though this could be seen as a rescue
i actually have a different theory about
what's going on
now clearly the curse has ravaged a lot
of things and i think that the survivors
will be forced to join the military
or participate in their experiments i
think season two will definitely open up
the rest of the country
and from this finale i got a lot of
resident evil vibes here
with it hinting to me at least that the
season will be set in the city
rather than just one key location i'll
talk about the deal that yai makes in
just a bit as
i think that ties heavily in with
hunsu's fate but yeah
there's a lot of things going on here
now an interesting thing that happens is
that we actually see
one hook remain behind in the apartment
building and though
he would likely die due to the
bombardment the character has a
nosebleed indicating that he's become a
monster and will survive this encounter
however if he doesn't and this is the
last time that we see the character
it also feels like somewhat of a fitting
end for him throughout the season
many people viewed him as having no
empathy because he was willing to make
the tough choices in order to save the
group
however i actually think that he's the
complete opposite and understands that
everything must be sacrificed in order
for the greater good
this was demonstrated in his actions in
which the character ended his education
so that jung yoo could continue her
training as a ballerina
and i see this moment as a
self-quarantined so that he can save
them from potentially being gunned down
due to him being amongst them however i
do think that the character will return
down the line at some point
and this is why we close in on him with
a nose bleed rather than a shot of his
body
to me he seems like a special infection
similar to hyunsu
so he may return looking normal and be
more open to working with the other
monsters
now the finale ends with hyunsoo's
memories coming back to him
as he heads towards the military it
initially seems like they took him
captive
as we do pick up with him in a military
vehicle
but it's quickly revealed that this
isn't the case when we see that sang
works driving it
and there are two possibilities here
either sang work transformed and he
became a monster
or you took over him the first is
possible because we know
very little about sang-wook and though
he initially appeared to be a criminal
i think it became more apparent
throughout the series that he actually
wasn't
there was a lot of talk about spies and
so on i think that sang work
may have actually been one of them he
did pretend to be unable to do a lot of
things to hide certain secrets
and this only really seems plausible if
there was a greater mission at play that
he wasn't willing to discuss
so this could indeed be sang work
revealing that he is special ops
and the military could have captured
hyunsoo which then allowed him to break
the character out for the finale
however it also could be yoo myeong and
judas sangwook's apparent death
this would give him the perfect
opportunity to sneak in and take his
body
it also explain the truck and lack of
burns
as these were key things that took a lot
of focus in the end
personally i side more with that theory
as it just seems the most plausible
and he of course would want to save hyun
soo because he views them as both being
wolves
wolves upper right in packs and clearly
he has big plans for the character
i think that their fates will become
interlinked with the key characters and
the deal
now yi in the end was forced to join
back up with the military
and because she didn't use the beacon
the commanding officer cancelled their
deal
however it looks like they struck a new
one that's obviously connected to her
fiance
i think she's going to be trying to work
back into the good books in order to
write the wrong set the commanding
officer sees her is doing
i think that going forward she will
become pivotal in tracking down hyun-soo
and whichever theory you take in regards
to sang work
the military are clearly aware of him
yoo myeong is wearing one of their
outfits which the sang work we saw die
wasn't
so he's probably came face to face with
them and is likely now a target
i actually think that the military are
trying to weaponize the monsters
and this is why they were experimenting
on yumyong they might potentially end up
carrying out the same sort of procedures
on the survivors
and this will lead to both hyun soo and
yum young teaming up against them
clearly the latter hates them because of
what they did to him and the former
could want to take them out in order to
save his friends
that's all the theories i have for the
moment but i'd of course love to hear
yours on the ending
and what you took from it don't forget
that on the 30th of december we're
giving away three copies of the lord of
the rings 4k box set to our subscribers
all you have to do to be on the chance
of winning is like the video make sure
you subscribe with notifications
on and drop a comment below with your
thoughts on the season
if you want something else to watch then
make sure you check out our breakdown of
the flight attendant which will be
linked on screen right now
we go over the season and give our
theories on where things could be going
in the future
so it's definitely worth checking out if
you want to know more by the way
thank you for sitting through the video
i've been paul i'll see you next time
take care peace